hi there Steve Kaufman here um I've been
asked to do a video on how I learned
Mandarin now I thought I had done a
video on that subject cuz I've done
videos on how I learned other languages
but I haven't done when I guess on
Mandarin I looked through my youtube
videos couldn't find any so I'm going
from memory and first of all I'm doing
this it's a request that I received from
I think his name was Frederick from
Denmark please excuse me if I can't
remember the first name I'm not going to
be bothered mucking it up right now uh
and I'm gonna do it in English and then
I'm gonna do in Japanese because I
haven't done a Japanese video in quite a
while so it all started back in 1967 I
believe I was in the Canadian government
Trade Commissioner service I found out
that they were going to send someone to
to honk or somewhere to learn Chinese
because they needed to train someone up
in Mandarin because Canada was getting
ready to recognize the People's Republic
of China so I immediately started taking
lessons from a guy at the Taiwanese
Embassy it was a hopeless teacher I
didn't learn much but I was able in a
couple of six weeks or so to tell my
bosses in the Diplomatic Service that I
am interested and what's more I have
already started studying and that sort
of gave me the inside track and so then
they said oK we've decided you're going
to be our language student and you have
a choice you can go to moderate the US
defence Institute language school there
or you go to Hong Kong and so I said I
want to go to Hong Kong and of course
Hong Kong is Cantonese speaking but in
those days they have the Cultural
Revolution going on in China and Taiwan
was a very suitable place if you wanted
to participate in dealings with the
People's Republic they were very fussy
on both sides about people who were
involved in either of the other called
the other China so and then I went to
Hong Kong and I decided I had a choice
between the Hong Kong University on Hong
Kong side very comfortable right by all
the beaches or down in
Kowloon in amongst all the crowds of
Chinese people and I decided to go to
Kowloon and study at the new China
College Yale in China
center there so I live in Kowloon sorry
used to take my scooter to the school
every day was very hot there was no
air-conditioning ah and I'm going from
memory now but we had classes we might
have had five hours a day to start with
but I very soon said that's too much so
I switched to three hours a day a lot of
the classes consisted of drills but I
would say that my major activity I
should say at the outset that basically
I passed the British Diplomatic Service
advanced exam after essentially 10
months 9 10 months of study which was
twice as fast more than twice as fast as
as previous language students and the
main reason I did that is because I read
and listened an awful lot I mean
everyone had classes many had more
classes than I did with drills month in
another but I just read a lot so what I
want to show you here oh is yeah we
started out with a thing called Chinese
dialogues and I still remember that
everyone thought that they were read so
quickly that we could I mean are they
are they deliberately trying to talk so
fast that we can't understand we felt
and Chinese dialogues has no Chinese
characters in it it is all in way Jiles
which is the equivalent of pinyin it was
the romanization system that was used in
those days so I listened to that many
many many many times it was a story
about people travelling from Shanghai to
Peking or whatever and of course we
couldn't travel in those places so it
sounded a bit unrealistic but it was
kind of an it initiation of the language
and you always have to start with some
kind of beginner material so the Chinese
dialogues was our introduction to
Chinese but very quickly thereafter we
got out of the stuff that was more
interesting and I can show you what my
reading consisted of the next book I
went to was this 20 lectures in Chinese
culture a great book and that got you
into the history
of China so it was actually interesting
and that makes it a lot easier to learn
from I think I also managed to I was
always prowling around the bookstores in
Hong Kong and I found geography books
and history books written for people
with limited character knowledge just a
word on characters we had flashcards
written by one hand written by one of
our teachers at mr. Wei and beautifully
handwritten
and a thousand these flashcards and I
learned my first thousand characters
from the flashcards and I mentioned this
before I had this squared paper and I
would pick the first flashcard write the
character if it was war write the
character ten times and put war or the
meeting I three columns over on this
squared paper then I picked the next one
up which might be pop and then I go Tata
Tata Tata then I write Todd or he over
you know another few guys and I kept on
doing that and eventually of course you
run into the first character you've
written so it's kind of like a primitive
spaced repetition system and I started
out with ten characters a day and I've
actually gotten up to thirty but of
course I keep I kept on shuffling in the
characters that I had already learned
because my retention rate was whatever
twenty thirty percent every day so but
nevertheless in doing that and in
reading a lot you know and of course
noticing you know the components of the
characters and so forth pretty soon my
the number of characters I had increased
so the next book I went to and I still
claim this is the best Chinese book I've
ever and one of the best language
learning books I've ever come across
it's called intermittent intermediate
reader in modern Chinese I mean this is
what I used in 1968 so that's getting on
in years here and I loved it because it
introduced you to authentic material
there were you know texts from and don't
forget as I'm learning Chinese I'm
getting into you know not only to some
extent ancient history but mostly the
history act post nineteen not nine
eleven nineteen eleven the nationalist
revolution and that whole period where
different thinkers are commenting on the
impact of the West and how they but they
should do and and of course the
Warlord's and Sun yat-sen and all those
kind stuff and so these here are
documents many of them from that period
and you work your way through until you
start to get to you know the communist
period so it had you know the actual
text and then in had glossary phenomenal
glossary and it had patterns and the way
you know and I they had all kinds of s1
ep-1
I could never figure out what a lot of
this stuff meant you know VP 1 plus s 2
plus side
yo Nam clay K so jury Oh blah blah blah
sigh yo sign on psycho II so I would get
the hang of drilled
type to real time okay that means only
when Emma can you so that was a pattern
or jury on jokowi
triage okay so they would introduce all
those that I'll be I'll be sure so they
would use wit Levin a Chichen so they
would introduce all these patterns and I
would focus on the patterns and then I
would read these texts and I would
review the vocabulary and I spent I
don't know a good measure to on the
intermediate reader and that's where I
really charged ahead of other people
because that then took me up to quite a
significant level by then we were
starting to read the newspaper and most
of what we read was communist newspapers
and we were into you know our good
friend Mao Zedong their [ __ ] Genji and
we would read this some of his stuff and
Jimmy boring it's the same stuff over
and over again but I was able to go down
to the bookstores and I read on my own
much more than anybody else so I read
here we have readings and contemporary
Chinese literature essays and all of
these books had glossaries oh well in
the hair should point out you see you
have the glasses and you'll notice that
the glossaries are just full of my
scratchings full
my scratchings underlines trying to
notice trying to remember do whatever I
can to try to remember all these you
know turn
so that was one there's a whole
collection of them what we got here
this is a reading favorite Chinese
literature Volume one plays and poems
readings in contemporary Chinese
literature I mean this was a great book
and all of the leading writers of China
in the 1920s and 30s are here and and
some wonderful stories being my all-time
favorite collegiate written by Lucian
and what have you got here selected
readings in Chinese communist
literature's are more of the same stuff
so you know I read all that stuff and
all these books of course come with
glossary here's an Aleutian reader as
well and it also comes with a glossary
most of them are from the Yale in China
series ah then of course a major I also
attempted literary Chinese but we didn't
have to do it and I just find it to
different to relevant to my situation
was fun if I if I ever have the time
I'll go back and I'd like to do it so
then came a point where I was actually
able to read my first novel all by
myself without the glass roots Lotus
yawns okay this is the rickshaw boy by
Lau sure I mean that was a major
achievement for me so that no that was
my reading and I haven't got all the
books like I got lots of books I read
tons and I listen I listen we had a
history of the Second World War we had
you know tapes from our dialogues or
from our what we were reading and then
that the big revelation was the
disjunction and I don't have him here
but I've got tons of sunshine CDs my
favorite is whole wall in but I used to
listen to songs because that gets the
rhythm of the language going so I was
attending my classes I was reading I was
listening and basically that was it and
we had to write so I wrote and that
basically got me to where I passed the
test but my Chinese is much better today
than it was when I wrote the exam
because I have continued and there's so
much stuff available for Chinese
learning you know I go to buy books you
know junghwa 2001 park IL guilin so
they're you know I read a book on
Chinese culture then there's a tomb or
surgeon yeah okay so you can read a bit
about Chinese history I haven't read the
whole thing but I've read different
parts of it when I get interested when I
get interested in the certain erewan
then read on that era I have other
Chinese books I have one that's a
translation of a Cambridge history
because this tends to be very much the
sort of Chinese Communist you know
scientific whatever they call it has
something other dialectical materialism
or some such nonsense
ah but I read it meet other sources as
well the you know there if you if you're
into audio I mean there is no place
where there are more audio books audio
material than in China you know you can
get audio stuff on on history you know
on philosophy allows the drums up you
know jungle Essure or you can get this
whole series here which is Goemon or you
know trail would run so i mean there is
just no shortage of stuff all I don't
have is time because I've been busy
learning you know Russian and check and
I'm working on Korean and so forth but
so I mean I'm trying to trying to
remember all the things that I did I'd
like to get into more history you know I
bought I buy lots of books I got like
ten times this number of books half of
which I've never read this one here is a
fascinating collection of articles about
history and of course it has all these
historical references and one of the
reasons one of my thoughts when we got
involved in setting up link is if I
could read this electronically and every
time a name came up you know it's a
fascinatingly it's a very nicely
illustrated book every time a name came
up if I could click on that name place
name or name of a famous person and get
all kinds of background on that person
and save it into my database so I start
accumulating just as I accumulate
vocabulary and like I've got
accumulate my knowledge of personalities
in Chinese history maybe one day if I
ever get the time to do it or if these
kinds of you know online encyclopedias
that you can link to while you're
reading in Chinese if these ever become
available so there you have it
overwhelmingly reading and listening and
I'm finding now with with my Korean that
that a lot of the sort of simple
beginner stuff I can't hack it didn't
with check one month and I'm out of
there I've got I would rather struggle
with something that's difficult read it
build up my vocabulary and at a certain
point you have enough words that now you
can go back and you can start
communicating with people and so forth
but but to have to struggle with stuff
that is written at a level that has if
only got so many new words and therefore
they only introduce simple words and
therefore the content is very simple and
stuff I no longer have the patience to
do that you have to get into the real
stuff and that's what I did with with
Chinese at an early stage and that's why
I think I was able to do it more quickly
than essentially any other students who
were in the Diplomatic Service whether
Canadian American Japanese or whatever
back in Hong Kong in 1968 so there you
have it and Frederic I hope that answers
your question let me know if you have
any any other questions thanks for
listening bye for now